[Musique]
dans cette vidéo de boeing le pilote
d'essai prend des risques au décollage
l'angle du 737 max est tellement
verticale qu'il est à la limite du
décrochage avec ses moteurs plus gros et
plus en avance on est surélevée il est
plus susceptible de décrocher juste
après le décollage
c'est ce que doit empêcher le logiciel
mks que boeing a conçu en rabaissant
l'appareil vers le sol la certitude est
un talent que celle mk ce qui est à
l'origine des deux s'écrase mme
passionnés d'aéronautique gilles primo à
étudier de près les écrasements des
boeing 737 max de la ionnaires
éthiopienne cet ingénieur a consacré une
grande partie de sa carrière à la
sécurité des systèmes de commande
d'avions chez plusieurs constructeurs la
veille de l'écrasement du vol 610 de la
nr en novembre 2018 le même avion a
connu des problèmes avec le logiciel mks
en voici le graphique en jaune les
interventions automatique du mks à
chaque fois les pilotes corrigent le
logiciel fautif en bleu sur le graphique
ils le font en appuyant sur
l'interrupteur en haut à gauche du
manche à balai ce qui a déclenché le mkc
la différence entre les deux courbes des
capteurs d'incidence
normalement les lignes des deux capteurs
verte et rouge doivent se confondre la
rouge indique que l'angle de monter de
l'appareil est trop verticale alors le
logiciel le corrige en le poussant vers
le bas à l'aide des stabilisateurs
arrière un pilote qui n'était pas en
service se trouvait dans le cockpit
il réalise ce qui se passe et il
désactive le logiciel ils ont désactivé
les deux interrupteurs sur les pédales
taxe apple stable
quant à ses skis comme si vous voulez
l'alimentation matière de l'actu
le vol se poursuit normalement en
pilotage manuel
l'événement du presque quatre minutes et
un point très important c'est qu'il ya
eu plusieurs témoignages
suite à ces vols de fortes odeurs dans
la cabine de caoutchouc ou femme brûlée
le lendemain le même avion le même vol
610 disparaît dans la mer de java
ces pilotes n'ont pas eu la même chance
ils n'ont pas compris ce qui se passait
données montrent les mêmes incidents de
la veille les lignes vertes et rouges
des capteurs d'incidence en désaccord on
ne sait pas pourquoi mais le logiciel se
fie à un seul des capteurs ce que boeing
viennent corriger c'est celui du pilote
qui est défaillant actuelle parce que
c'est lui qui donne une valeur beaucoup
plus élevés plus lent d'attaqué
tellement puis vous vous approchez du
décrochage en jaune déclenchement du
logiciel mk ce qui pousse l'appareil
vers le bas en bleu les impulsions des
pilotes qui le désactive le mk se
remette en marche après des pauses de 10
secondes dans lequel la n165 entre la
première pile dames 4 et la dernière
autant duquel le plongeon final s'initie
malheureusement ça dure 6 min 10
secondes et tout ça se produit depuis de
longues minutes et un moteur qui
s'occupe de faire l'actu sion qui est en
train de surchauffe et faire tourner ce
moteur la sous charge
mais cannes est aussi longtemps est tout
à fait anormal
le graphique montre que plus rien ne
bouge
à l'arrière le moteur ne répond plus les
pilotes perdent le contrôle
juste avant un crash les deux colonnes
ceux des couples est un des deux pilotes
tirent avec environ 100 livres loti avec
60 lits ils sont en désespoir de cause
et je crois que c'est l'heure pour les
entend faire la prière même si l'enquêté
n'est pas terminée on sait que le vol ne
t'est 302 d'éthiopiens n'a connu les
mêmes problèmes de mks des témoins l'ont
vu s'écraser comme dit qu'il a vu du feu
et de la fumée dans la queue de l'avion
qui l'a vu tanguay et piqué du nez vers
le sol
je peux vous dire que c'était aussi
indéniable que le moteur électrique de
l'actu terre sollicités ainsi à
surchauffer ce j'en suis absolument
assurer ensuite ajouté des témoignages
de fortes odeurs dans le volet qui
précède la nr et ce jeune homme qui dit
avoir vu de la fumée ou les flammes
s'échapper de la queue de la
l'oeil c'est exactement la constituer
cette actuateurs c'est pour ça qu'à mon
avis boeing a réduit demandé de clouer
au sol sa propre flotte
gilles primeau est convaincu qu'avec ses
défauts de conception
le 737max n'aurait jamais dû être
certifié par la f1 l'agencé américaine
de sécurité aérienne chez bombardier
chez mitsubishi chez gulf stream
chez ander kraft ce sont les années les
avionneurs pour qui j'ai travaillé un
truc comme ça il ya vert pour que moi
comme ingénieur qui aura dit un instant
qu est ce qui est arrivé à bruges ronald
c'est pas cessé 6,7 à berre on sait que
boeing a lancé son 737 max très
rapidement qu'en 2011 pour concurrencer
le a320 d'airbus
un avion plus modernes ou commande
électronique